i think putin knows that in the long run  china is a bigger threat to russia than  the west  and that he's better he knows that i  think he knows that i think it's obvious  you know when you when you look at  world war ii exactly  well what's obvious is that russia has a  shared border with china as a  diminishing population and a diminishing  economy china is greedy for the natural  resources including in siberia and and  territory i think putin knows that the  russians are chess players you know that  after world war three suppose there is a  world war three and to defeat us okay  there's gonna be a world war iv and  that's gonna be between  the new access  you know russia and china will confront  each other in that world war four